the other day went to a cigar bar no i
don't know what it is about having a fat
cigar in your hand
you just you just you just want to talk
business and you're like you take up you
take a puff you're like
we have a problem we need to eliminate
someone
there's we got exterminated
i remember we went for uh cigars with
pewdiepie right
yeah yeah yeah and uh he was like damn
your voice got even deeper with the
signal
i was like i was made for this feeling
the first time i saw that i was like oh
my god i could finally understand why
mafia bosses
feel so powerful with a cigar in their
hand because it's like it's got an
energy to it yeah yeah
yeah i don't i never smoke like at all
but for some reason yeah the idea of
cigar i was like that sounds good i like
that well because unlike a cigarette
right like you don't inhale the cigar
smoke right yeah so i mean
like don't get me wrong it's still bad
for you it's still terrible it's still
terrible for you
you come out of the bar smelling like
you've just like puffed an exhaust pipe
yeah
that's that's kind of the smell the
smell that yeah but man you feel
so powerful like just with that aura of
cigar
around you like yes i just came out of
the cigar
i want all of it i do business yeah you
do have like a different aura around you
don't you yeah yeah just feel powerful
yeah it's it's like when you order a
drink
at a bar it's like you're like the
virgin when you order a drink at the
cigar bar it's like oh there's a chat he
said
[Music]
espresso martini if you haven't had it
it's an amazing drink
uh it's just coffee just with a vodka
base yeah
pretty much it's amazing it tastes it's
just coffee with attitude really i love
my i love my cookies
am i not wrong what a terrible way to
decide it's a coffee with attitude
that's like it is describing anything
why are you
i'm right because it's such a like i
don't know that sounds like a
howard disney character that he
introduced in a in a short
oh yeah he's the bully with attitude
i'll take a coffee with attitude please
hold the attitude
yeah i hate it here i hate it yeah
it's like today when you got a
frappuccino and you're like
no i didn't just get a frappuccino i got
an espresso fragrance you know
it's like oh my god you couldn't enough
sanity any more white it's like 35
celsius i want to i want an ice cream
and a drink in one
but i also want a coffee so yeah i don't
i normally think
uh frappuccinos are awful but i you know
i bent my own morals yeah so you
basically got a frappuccino with
attitude
right okay i hate it here i hate it so
much
just add anything with attitude it'll
just make it sound bad all
the [ __ ] comments now are gonna be
like damn that was something without it
yeah
i want that to be a meme oh no that's
gonna be a meme now